[Music]
don't slow down
well that's
obviously he's trying to play very fast
but when you want to play fast the first
thing you have to do is relax hi my name
is antonio sanchez i'm a jazz drummer
and composer i'm a four-time grammy
winner and i did the film score for
birdman today we're going to be looking
at drum scenes from films and tv and
judging how real they are
are there any drummers in the house
i play percussion just see if you can do
what i do okay just give it a try
the main thing to notice here is they
only have a snare drum
a floor tom
which is basically not even half of the
drum set and then the crash this is a
kind of small symbol there's no bass
room
and there's no hi-hat this is the school
of rock you need a bass drum
it's like the heartbeat of the whole
thing so those are really not at all the
elements that you would need to do a
good rock
groove
[Music]
okay so far
the kid is doing a good job
because he's doing what he told them to
do the main challenge for somebody who's
coming from classical percussion
to play drum set
it would be how to coordinate your feet
and your hands classical percussionists
don't use their feet too much
good okay no that's bad that's like
george of the jungle play it up here on
the symbol but really light
oh that's it okay let's go
[Music]
i don't think it was the
the right choice the song is playing is
deep purple smoke on the water what you
need in that song is like a big back
beat
and again he doesn't have the bass drum
and the hi-hat so i would have him maybe
try to imitate the bass drum on the
floor tone like
something like that having said that i
know jack black is a good musician and
you know what he told him to play he did
play give it a nine or a 10.
one thing that i noticed right off the
bat he looks
relaxed and he's hitting hard too he's
hitting as a rock drummer that's not
easy to do it's kind of easy to get
injured if you don't know what you're
doing he definitely put some work into
it
[Music]
everything
so far that i've seen
totally matches with with what i've
heard for example in this section i can
hear
a double bass drum which in this case
you would have a pedal it's called a
double pedal that has two beaters that
are hitting the same
bass drum and then you play like if you
had two bass drums but you're only
playing on one and to me it sounds like
he would have a double pedal so you can
hear that
from the
double bass drum and
the hands just doing the symbol
[Music]
it doesn't sound to me like they're
trying to focus on a groove or a
specific tempo it's more like an energy
so she's screaming and she's playing
fast and loud playing around a tonal
center and making sort of like a wall of
sound like almost if they're playing
free and that seems like the right
choice for that particular tune i'll
give it a 10 it impressed me how well he
played for him not to be a professional
drummer
[Music]
don't slow down
i'm just not sure
what the drummer is doing obviously he's
trying to play very fast but
when you want to play fast the first
thing you have to do is relax instead of
tensing up that's why you have to start
practicing slow so that you can feel
the movement how everything works
together the right hand with the left
hand and the left foot on the right foot
and then you start speeding up little by
little but just looking at the faces
he's making while he's playing it was
like if he was lifting weights and
trying to see how much
he can go before breaking the body is
one thing but if you start
getting tensed up in your head
then that's the beginning of the end
pick it up
i didn't hear the song but traditionally
caravan is not a very hard song to play
and it's not a very fast song to play
either for example there are other songs
that are traditionally very
fast there's one called lover
and
the melody goes
[Music]
the drums are supposed to play kind of
double time on top of it caravan is not
one of those
caravan is usually like a medium up
[Music]
although i didn't hear the arrangement
maybe if they have an amazing
arrangement that justifies the song
being that fast you can do it
whatever it is that he's doing
it's not music i don't hear any real
tempo i don't hear a clear pattern when
you're playing jazz at a very fast tempo
you start usually with quarter notes on
the right symbols which is one two three
four one two three four then the right
pattern which is the quintessential jazz
bebop pattern which is what makes it
swing is one two three four one two
three four chain change again
we don't have a hi-hat today but that
would be going and two and four one two
three four one two three four that's the
basic pulse and then on your left hand
you would be just kind of conversing on
what's going on with the music and then
you speed that up
[Music]
but nothing he was doing was relating to
that there's no pulse there's no finesse
there's no new ones so it's just like
like a broken washing machine
that's the pulse that's what he should
be playing to but you would hear
both of them intersecting and
to my ears they're really not if you
want your drummer to play
intended you would not play that but the
cowboy is a great instrument too
to play really loud so that the drummer
could hear
[Music]
well that's
the amount of blood that there is on the
drums right now
that's kind of staggering the only times
where i bled is i
hit
the edge of the hi-hat you can open one
of your knuckles
a little bit but that amount of blood on
the drums that's a sign that something
very bad is being done i would probably
rate it at a you know one it
kind of shows that
speed for the sake of speed there's no
finesse there's no nuance so there's no
music really
my shoulders and my neck hurt just by by
watching him play i remember this guy
there was a famous clip going on he was
doing all that stuff i remember watching
it and i was laughing because it looked
so crazy but he sounded really good to
me it's very hard
because i've always emphasized trying to
make the least amount of movement and
get the most out of the sound and he's
doing the most amount of movement he
possibly can having said that he plays
great
[Music]
the grooves and licks that steve is
playing they're fairly complicated a
lick is basically a pattern that you
learn that you can throw at any given
moment so if you do
that's one lick
[Music]
well kevin
didn't necessarily play any drums he
just hit the cymbal a couple of times
and that's it
you can tell he's
never really played a drum set in in his
life which is fine i think that's the
idea of the scene
twirling
throwing sticks up in the air they're
not necessarily
connected to the music
but if you want cool visuals and
showmanship
they can be very effective when
you do
those kinds of tricks and the music
suffers because of that then i think you
should re-evaluate what you're doing 10
for sure everything they're trying to
demonstrate that he's playing he's doing
it
[Music]
it wasn't that bad that's a very simple
drum beat when it comes to drumming
styles there's some that are inherently
easier than others rock is usually where
you start because it's one of the most
simple
ways to create already like a cool beat
if you're going to do
spats that that already sounds good
anybody with
decent hand-eye coordination would
probably pull that off in a day or two
it's not totally lining up with what
you're hearing movies for some reason
they usually don't get the syncing with
the image and the music really well done
drums is very precise with guitars or
bass you cannot really tell that much
because there's not that clear attack
as when you were trying to hit something
which is
kind of doing it the technique is leaves
a lot to be desired because she's
grabbing the sticks so in the middle you
get no power from that because all the
weight that you would be able to hit the
drums with it's not there you need to
find the place in the stick where it
will bounce by itself the most if you
hold it
really far back it would just go like
pop and just die out and be holding
really to the front of the stick the
stick would bounce and then kind of fall
back
so you have to find the sweet spot and
usually the sweet spot is like three
quarters back
into the stick in that situation the
drums would sound really puny
you can totally look that relaxing and
play a good rock beat drummers it
doesn't matter if they're jazz or rock
they should be relaxed usually rock
drummers have a little bit more of an
attitude a lot more
kind of big gestures even if they're
doing something simple like she's doing
instead of playing on the hi-hat she's
playing on the floor tom so
which is like the white stripes that's
what they would be known for that kind
of a beat i would say probably a seven
or an eight she didn't do such a bad job
so that's
one thing many people maybe don't know
exactly what it's called or why people
play this way what he's playing here is
called traditional grip which takes a
lot longer to learn when you play
traditional grip these two fingers are
kind of not doing much
you have to find
different ways to make this two fingers
do the work of all these four fingers
and then you're doing it with your weak
hand which is the left in terms of like
he's doing it or the way i do it so then
you have to work twice as hard to get
some of the same finesse and speed when
you think why don't both hands just do
exactly the same thing that's called
match grip the traditional grip comes
from the old marching bands people would
play this way so that there was an
incline on the snare drum and then it
was very easy to play right here by your
side while you were walking or marching
i think his playing showcases the fact
that he's coming more from a jazz
background usually people that play
traditional grip come more from jazz
sounds good what he started playing
was totally accurate for that time
period in the 60s and 70s too like for
example the beach boys would had a lot
of songs that had that kind of vibe
[Music]
that would be very similar to the
kid that ringo stark would play with the
beatles it's a four piece kit they call
it so yeah it's it's accurate it sounded
good and it felt good i think 10.
[Music]
that's a 100 accurate the first thing
you would do when you sit down
would be just to hit everything a couple
of times just to see what it sounds like
and then you would probably start with
some kind of groove or a couple of fills
depends also what style of
drumming you like and what you play but
if you were going to play rock that's
pretty much it
that would have been my dream drum kit
back then in the 80s this was like a
thing for example rush neil paired had a
gigantic kit this drum set is in what
they call a cage
which is
it's like a metal bar that goes around
the drum set where you set everything on
top which was very popular during the
80s but
what i notice is that he's just using
the left side of the kit normally your
right leg would be on the right bass
room and i know dana carvey he actually
plays the drums
and he absolutely playing everything we
heard
[Music]
drum solos can be anything you can have
a completely prepared drum solo or you
can completely improvise what you're
going to do so there's really no correct
or incorrect way to play a solo usually
in a rock context that's fairly accurate
but you kind of keep
some kind of
pulse happening and then you do a bunch
of fails and it's just kind of meant to
get the crowd going what he did is not
particularly hard but it's not
particularly easy
either you need a couple of years under
your belt but the drumming itself is
definitely real 10
for sure lately my favorite drum
movie
even though the plot is is very sad is
uh the sound of metal everything
you see gives you the impression that
it's actually happening thanks for
watching and if you enjoyed this video
why not click on the video above